this surpassing NFL on Instagram I
thought this is a big deal because well
it's kind of surprising that's kinda it
just cuz how [ __ ] big the NFL is I
mean then it felt so big yeah UFC passed
them but also it kind of makes sense
because I didn't read article but with
UFC it's a young six males and they're
so social media savvy so they're gonna
be more willing because like if every
NFL fan that an Instagram NFL would
completely annihilate the UFC but they
don't how did this steep a core me if I
do pay-per-view yeah I don't do how I
saw the prelims what was sixth and it
was a bottom six out of the eight ESPN
Dan Williams not great yeah hmm so let's
see the UCS seventy million or the NBA
has forty minutes but this is all yeah
this is the total for all of them but
then you see here NFL fourteen point
nine UFC fifteen and the NBA is just
like boom and big but here's the thing
and be a younger demo the more kids are
on there they always post cool dunks and
highlights like the NBA's a younger kids
game NFL old or right you know yeah the
day Chris Bosh really good guy really
really nice guy
oh it's a basketball player yeah yes it
was at my house one of my co-stars so
tall what are you I'm just hanging out
my friend Chris bothers Chris Bosh's
here do you want to say hi just hang a
sixteen knows no see Jen
yes either you have to retire from a
issue in is like oh six eleven six like
yeah you know I'm insane go back to that
thing no chin um 15mph 14 mil yeah then
base kicking their ass MLB nine close
again older game
yeah wow that's not surprising I don't
think it means that much either you know
it's not like oh UFC is taking over look
at MLB older game five million Lea NHL
three million that's terrible
I wonder what the NFL's gonna do to
attract the younger audience because
because now like kids
growing up there's so much emphasis on
brain trauma and CT well we should talk
about what's-his-name retiring Andrew
Luck yeah I mean you know that nine
eight seven seasons though
well he's 29 still has a I mean Drew
Brees is forty Tom Brady's forty two
football quarterbacks are playing longer
than ever this guy's so gifted but it's
very interesting that he would do this
he was an architecture major from
Stanford very smart Stanford yes like my
boy Pat Mac he was like smartest guy
I've ever been I have no doubt yeah and
also though I was looking at his
injuries a lacerated kidney from Athiya
I mean and and also you have you know
that's really liver
what yep [ __ ] yeah yeah and then
cartilage ripped from his you know and
then obviously leg he had a major leg
injury he had a lot of injuries crazy
yeah
out for a whole season with the shoulder
mm-hmm so I mean after a while you're
like yeah in my head [ __ ] this
I wonder if you're gonna see more of
this he could have made a hundreds of
millions dollars more they say but once
you're okay so torn college cartilage
and two ribs parts a torn abdomen
lacerated kidney at least one concussion
torn labrum and mysterious calf ankle
issues
to be honest not bad standard not bad
no there's guys wait wait where's than
this that's not I mean I guess what I'm
saying is a torn labrum is doing
shoulder for a core back sucks but
there's been way worse but but if you
have nothing major on there but if you
have if you have options if you have
options like he does as in architecture
major as in as in a hundred million
dollars in the bank I can understand how
you just find a percent rocket right
because also remember when he was
drafted that was when first picks got
paid but then all the vets like this
isn't fair they're getting paid more
than you know veterans and guys whom
into him forever so they now they're
there's only a standard minimum or
maximum that guys need to pay but okay
so sadly the contract he know him and
Cam Newton were like the last ones who
really got paid his first round
Oliver Spitz yeah he got a hundred
million dollar contract or some crazy
amount so signed a five-year hundred
twenty two million dollar contract you
set to earn a salary of nine million to
a nineteen
roster bonus twelve million yeah but so
he signed that too on sixteen so he
served three years of that they'll
scroll down cuz his rookie contract he
got a guarantee just put on it um maybe
I wonder how about this because oh the
hon so luck signed a five-year hundred
twenty minute contract you said during a
base salary of nine roster bonus of
twelve yeah so he's not gonna see that
money he's gonna see some of it but type
in Andrew Luck rookie contract that was
that what that would be the money that
he had typing Cooke rookie contract yeah
Andrew Luck rookie contract because that
that one hundred twenty two million
dollar contract he's not gonna the only
served I think two years of that luck
signed four-year deal Colts were twenty
two million twenty twelve twenty twelve
so he has that smart guy with his money
doesn't live crazy I wonder what a
signing bonus was so you know yeah hey
probably gave up on a million dollars
but for your health
yeah how much is enough it's a lot of
[ __ ] money in the bank yeah depending
how you live right yeah question is
you're gonna see more of that my
prediction is as we learn more so so so
I was listening to steep a speak at his
that was a present but I believe he was
still slurring his words I think he had
took a lot of brain damage and I think
he I've been thin and I know it's not a
popular opinion but I said this to Rogen
to I said do you know any other
english-speaking fighter with after you
subtitles
I've been around ste Bay before he is
UFC crazy strain was in Denver he was
not like that
how could just be maybe a broken jaw
whatever you want to say it is I would
assume that it's a good chance I would
say it's a good chance he took a
shitload of shots he got punched a lot
he's incredibly durable his brain got
[ __ ] rattled it's what Brennan an
hour after he fought two hours after he
fought he had he was slurring he was he
had brain damage there his he was not
himself he was concussed
so just last year luck made 26 or 27
million dollars and on this topic I
believe we're gonna look back on that
steep a thing in ten years as we learn
more about this stuff and we're gonna go
can you believe can you look at look at
all the signs look what he's doing this
is crazy and you think what again I
think most people know I think it's
gonna become measurably I think it's
gonna become measurable I think we're
gonna get more information sheet faster
we know we're just gonna know we're
gonna see look at all the signs and that
was what was going on it look at all the
shots you took and we're gonna see that
the human head can't take that that you
are gonna have repercussions yeah but we
know you you guys know it's bad for his
health right like we still wha
yeah so but I can t go hasty pay you're
gonna have brain trauma CT a few years
from now but you know you're the world
champion the world I tell you can say
okay yes I'm yep and hopefully for Steve
all of them was hopefully for Steve Bay
and I do believe this any way that your
brain can heal and you're bringing it
better there's no questions so if he
takes a lot of time off he's gonna be
fine he'll have a great life you know I
certainly I don't think it works that
way I hope it does had a career of
fighting and it doesn't work that way be
adhering that cuz I think he's awesome I
was telling running to that I don't
always felt that he had that weird kind
of like oh you know I'm telling you I
listen to that news conference but I
just understand what the [ __ ] he was
saying and we made a lot of people
didn't understand yeah I didn't like it
but I went to like older interviews and
he kind of has that same thing but I
guess maybe it sounds bad yeah right
yeah like sighs like I hope you're right
chin I hope you're right and I hope I'm
wrong but even takes T pay out of it if
you talk to any of these fighters
already attack the NFL guys okay you
know you hear a brain trauma right you
even when they're younger obviously yes
sign me up man every single it's
sometimes it's all worth the squeeze I
mean you know a football on you you care
your knees suck and you know but you
play pro football I mean it's what you
set out to do you know I mean it's like
telling a Navy SEAL hey dude it's really
dangerous yeah yeah I could lose my legs
yeah I think the bigger argument is they
should be cut like so Andrew Luck's 29
house T payees 32 multi-team world
champion heavyweight some you know you
could there's arguing is the best ever
at all
I'm he's 37 mmm so he's eight years
older than Andrew Luck Andrew Luck Prai
has 30 times more money than he does
like Andrew Luck can stop and we're like
yeah he's gonna be fine he's gonna live
a rich life well it's also a Stanford
Graduate in it with an architecture
degree he's got you know what mrs. D
buzzers do read - yes deeply and state
you know sure it's not Stanford but he's
an educated man of quiet fighter yeah I
mean steep he's gonna be fine either way
he's been a success all the way through
but I'm saying the bigger argument CT
brain trauma 107 has he taken would work
hold on what do you what do you think
you're watching of course not brain
trauma course MCD no one's gonna do [ __ ]
about it
everyone here is gonna keep watching so
whatever I got no but my fingers is
Andrew Luck he might have some injuries
and you might have a limp playing with
his kids but he's set for life yes steep
a is not that's the issue here come on
who do you think has taken more brain
trauma steep a right Oh see bear who the
order Andrew Luck steep a 100% right
yeah right because I mean training just
training Andrew Luck only gets hit in
the game right he gets hit when he's
faking sparring and it's direct head
trauma all the time yeah both of them
leaving in with a game yeah and then you
fight Daniel Cormier and take that kind
of punishment so my thing is this I'm
fan of contact sports I don't think they
should ever go away I think people may
be allowed to make the decision to do
whatever they want with their bodies III
think my question is is we learn more
about this I think you're gonna see
voluntarily you might even see
sanctioned you might even see the state
coming and saying you can you can do
this for seven years and that's it
because we have so much overwhelming
evidence of the price you're gonna pay
the other question though is like you
we've also seen there are a lot of
football players that played for a long
time and there's 65 or 70 you know I
have a [ __ ] thing so there is that
too
and I know one of the leading the
leading head trauma specialists at UCLA
and she was like you'd be surprised
there are a lot of people fighters who
are boxers who don't have any cognitive
issues but they have motor skills issues
so it all depends on what you're doing
you know
I don't know I'd say it's a it's a it's
a weird no it's not good yeah we know
getting hit in the head it's not we do
know now we I mean before remember why
are you watching you'll see wise girl we
didn't know yeah you see one two three
we thought that you can recover but then
now we know so everyone that's in the
UFC knows that that's nice cool when
you're going to do it developing
comedian in middle school even those
kids were right I mean you're tackling
and hitting pretty hard right yeah yeah
interesting
yeah that's interesting yeah the whole
bigger issue was debate should be set
for life and he's not yeah great do you
have any idea what he made for that
fight is it secret
I can't imagine more than four million
after taxes that's to I doubt they'll
show it though there's fighter payouts
I'm surprising without hi Brandon four
million I'm surprised that so it said
the says 750 thousand flat 504 DC but
there again bonuses
yeah formula that's that's me like just
when people know you're dealing he's not
set for your knots at MIT so flat fee so
he gets a flat fee of 800 or so 750
thousand DC gets a flat fee of five so
those flat fees though that's not they
they're making more than that yeah
people they are why because a bonus well
they they have certain things especially
as champion you get certain pay-per-view
point but with the ESPN deal I don't I
don't know man
I no one's making life-changing money
anymore that's why I think one of the
reasons you didn't see you're not seeing
Connor rushing back in that's one of the
reasons I think you know I can see Nate
Diaz amaz ball fight for a while because
they're not gonna pay Nate what he's
worth I think that's why Brock Lesnar
was like oh no I'm good that's the model
and I can't make the money up supposed
to make me then I'm out so I think
that's why you're not getting these real
big pay-per-view hitters back in the
game yeah but I killed the models change
they there's no way I'm gonna make why
should our Costa so I'm right let's say
even with bonuses I bet Sabri let's see
Stevie primary two million people if you
got paid a hundred down the same another
1.2 and bonuses
you know hmm you fight for a year before
that you got it yeah you got a fight
Cleveland goes right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]